hey Doug Walker here a few things real
fast first of all we are going to do
more Steven universe video logs we know
a giant bunch of episodes have been
dropped by so we are going to get to
that for those who are wondering with
these V logs and reviews uh secondly I
want to talk to you about The Killing
Joke and a funny story I have at the
very end of this I won't give it away
yet cuz I as a spoiler but it's
something funny about my observation of
the comic so funny little story at the
end ok let's get to this actual real
thoughts on The Killing Joke um because
everyone has been talking about this
recently and I said I don't want to talk
about it unless I have something new I
can talk about that everyone else isn't
talking about and I feel I do have
something I can talk about that not that
made people are talking about the actual
Killing Joke part because everybody
talks about the first half hour which is
completely understandable but they don't
really focus that much on the meat of
the story on what it was based on The
Killing Joke portion of it they mostly
focus on this first half hour and I will
talk about that briefly but I mostly
want to talk about the actual Killing
Joke part and Rob hasn't seen this yet
so while it's just gonna be mean in this
one so yeah I'll very quickly just
address the opening half hour everything
you heard is right it sucks it sucks
hard um and really it's it's just the
writing and I know it's like we mean
just the writing well because the
animation is good the voice acting is
fantastic even the pacing is good it's
got good angles it's visually
interesting the action is good all of
that is fine but this is some of the
worse writing ever but in a Batman
animated anything um and everything you
heard you probably know about yo Batman
and Batgirl have sex which is totally
how to left-field
it focuses on Batgirl the whole first
third it has nothing to do with The
Killing Joke at all like they don't even
weave it into the story or anything the
most it does is that shows why pecker
over tires which is really not a good
reason at least in my opinion
um and pretty much the big deal everyone
has about Batman bad girl having sex is
that you never felt like that was the
really
ship you feel more kind of like a nice
uncle kind of thing it's kind of like
suddenly finding out that like Batman
and Commissioner Gordon were having sex
it's like what's that the relationship
why do you just so does not fit and
maybe somewhere I don't know maybe
somewhere in the comic it happens but
it's not the relationship we're familiar
with I'd much more believe that Batman
and Jim Gordon are having sex before he
believed Batman and Batgirl are having
sex
uh and everything they say is right it
feels kind of misogynistic even if
they're trying to the only excuse I
could think of is that they're trying to
make what happens to her in The Killing
Joke a little more emotional because she
kind of shows up and then she's just
kind of gone in the story so but
everything with The Killing Joke is
establishing that this history already
exists and it's done through such clever
writing and I think that's the one last
thing I'll say about the first half-hour
is that the writing does not match the
rest of the writing at all I think
that's the biggest problem
I know people talk about you know the
way back row is done terribly and Batman
is done terribly and just everybody's
done terribly in terms of the writing
process but for me it's that none of the
writing just immediate difference as
soon as The Killing Joke stars you can
just tell everybody talks different
there's this just this kind of poetry to
the writing and I hate talking about
like that I know as pretentious and it's
it's not like The Killing Joke it's like
the perfect story but it's pretty damn
close um and you can just tell it's like
okay well now we have people writing
today for whatever just a DC animated
whatever and then just this phenomenal
writing this phenomenal dialogue like
when Christopher Nolan was at his best
in the Dark Knight movies like that's
The Killing Joke in fact so many of the
great Batman stories come from The
Killing Joke there are elements of you
know Dark Knight took elements from it
and Batman returned the Batman Beyond
vert or the Joker definitely took
elements from it so there's so many of
these elements in there and it comes
mostly from this one story so okay first
half-hour there right it sucks in my
opinion you could just fast-forward to
where you see the rain falling on the
ground just like in the comic
even Batgirl opens up saying you know
it's if you may be wondering why I'm
here and this wasn't the story that you
wanted well I'm gonna tell it to you
anyway that's literally how it opens up
uh but the funny thing about that is
that it is so separate from The Killing
Joke it is so separate from everything
else so bizarrely that for me anyway it
was very easy to separate the two so as
soon as The Killing Joke started I had
no problem
totally erasing the last half-hour I
mean it was gone just gone I had none of
it impacted the story at all so I'm just
like okay as soon as the actual Killing
Joke started I'm okay I am totally on
board with this and I'm ready to watch
and as The Killing Joke portion of this
goes like it's a half hour gone let just
imagine that doesn't exist I'm not going
to dress it anymore uh The Killing Joke
portion I think is good it's pretty damn
strong I've seen a couple of these
animated DC movies not a ton of em L
admit uh and it's about it's a little
better than them which I know some
people would think what this will be
great this will be phenomenal it's
pretty good and the reason for that is
um they try their damnedest to stick as
close to the comic as possible there's
both its strength and its weakness it's
its strength because one the writing is
just beautiful it is just phenomenal
writing um and hearing a Kevin Conroy
especially Mark Hamill say these words
you can tell he's been waiting forever
to say these words and he just it's like
listening to Shakespeare he just
delivers them so perfectly it's like
almost chill worthy how well he delivers
these lines and they try so hard to
capture the artwork like pretty much as
close as they can panel for panel they
really try to capture what the comic
looked like and that's tough and I know
you think it'd be very easy well it's
they're both hand drawn uh but it's very
very tough to incorporate that into
animation knowing what to keep still how
much of the shadow do you have in there
especially with CG coloring nowaday
and they find a really nice in-between
there's times where it needs to be
hand-drawn shadows understands where has
to be that CG kind of blur a little bit
and the gradient so they do a very very
good job and I originally thought that
Joker was going to look too different
from our Campbell's voice but but it
really works and Hamill both Hamill and
Conroy do a good job of just managing
them like when they first started doing
Batman the Animated Series and they do
sound a little different they sound like
they've aged but in a good way this is a
story where they're supposed to sound
like they've aged uh so I really felt
like that was there and that was very
very strong um the weakness of it is
that they try so hard to stick to it and
to get the panels and get word for word
for the most part as one or two
additions and one two things taken out
but they try so hard to keep to it that
there's times where more changes needed
to be made to make this great I'll give
you a perfect example uh the Joker is in
the amusement park he's buying this
amusement park and he's talking he's
being the Joker and he's making his
jokes he's gonna buy the place he's
gonna kill this person and then he looks
and he sees this picture of the fat lady
and I know what this is going to be this
is going to be a transition to his past
it's kind of remember when his wife was
pregnant so forth uh but they don't do
anything like that in terms of
transition they just dissolve they just
fade and there he is he's just there is
a young man he comes in and he's talking
to his wife and I felt why couldn't you
have a better transition this this whole
thing is so visually well done and the
shadows and there's all this sort of
visual psychological stuff going on why
couldn't you have more interesting
transition why couldn't you really have
it kind of they blend into each other he
talks about how his past he half the
time doesn't remember it it's almost
like multiple choice again something the
Dark Knight took from this but why
couldn't you have it more hazy why
couldn't you have it a little bit more
harder to figure out uh they just kind
of do the brown and white
they have a little bit jazz music
playing whenever it's on and I get
that's what the comic did to but I feel
like every single time there's a
flashback it's it's like the tiniest
hint that's like a trigger but they
don't even have like a white flash or
they don't even have like if there's so
many good transitions happening nowadays
I think in film ask because we do have
CG and we can do visually so many more
things are allowed and there's a scene
where it's like you know the scene where
he AVS Barbara there and he holds up the
glass aces to crime and you just
dissolve again to a flashback and at the
end of the flashback he's looking down
at his drink like oh that was the
trigger well why couldn't you have it
where it's like he holds the glass up
and then like when he puts it down he
suddenly the young man again like maybe
it's almost hard to even tell when it's
present when it's the past and I felt
like that was a huge missed opportunity
especially with animation and I think on
top of that like the scene I don't think
giving anything away
this guy transitions into the Joker you
know in these flashbacks and he goes
into panic chemicals he comes out and
he's got the white face he goes nuts
uh and I felt man they got some good
beginnings here because he takes off the
hood a looks die he sees his reflection
in this water that he's the Joker and he
just sir looks a starts laughing he does
the famous movies like this uh and I
felt why not drag that out even more why
not take a chance and have it be a long
period of kind of silent and maybe just
a little left and then it gets longer
and then it gets bigger and then just
turns this giant psychotic thing because
that's kind of what comics can do
everyone thinks it's just Oh panel to
panel panel to panel you just read it
all the way through but people forget
when there's like one panel of nothing
going on of no talking of just kind of
the silent moment it lasts a while when
you're reading it it isn't just a
picture and then the next picture it
really that because comics have so much
dialogue has so much going on so much
action that when there's a still moment
that really leaves an impact um so I
think it's something where there's some
moments where I really felt like man if
you took your time with this if you
really just said let's let's slow down
let's really take some time to sort of
see what we can do with this visually
and kind of with pacing and stuff I
think this could have been phenomenal
um and I hate to go back to it but with
the I do kind of wonder if like just
that first half hour if that wasn't
there and that didn't distract would we
have had more time put into this and
would we have had more things fleshed
out just a little bit more didn't need
much it just needed a little bit more um
I felt like this was like really really
close and I think the only Edition I can
recall in this that they added on top of
the first half-hour was that there's a
song sequence and I can't remember how
many words are in you know the original
comic or they made them all up um it's
okay I kind of heard about it didn't
know what to think of it it felt kind of
Joker the Joker would sing if he could
have a song and dance number while
showing these crucem photos like you
would do it um so it was okay I was kind
of hoping like again do this go even
more crazy uh or ya know just more crazy
you're supposed to be driving this guy
mad um but it's it's done fine I really
fell if you're gonna put in a song
sequence up you're gonna go that far the
Joker's planning a song sequence he's
gonna make it an amazing song sequence
and it's just kind of new you know it's
just sort of taking The Killing Joke and
putting a little song to it I thought
you could have really made that even
creepier and more psychotic you know you
could have done something really fun
with the music and sort of the visuals
even more beyond what's in the Killing
Joke gave you gotta add something really
add something but it's fine um the one
thing I felt didn't work in The Killing
Joke I kind of feel bad saying this I
did not like the voice actor did
Commissioner Gordon uh this is a guy who
you know your hearts supposed to be with
this guy you're supposed to feel so
sorry for this guy and just all the
torment he's both to go to Eddie this is
really in many respects the guy who's
pushed to the edge and it's I never
bought any of it I mean any of it this
did not feel like it didn't feel like
the Gary Oldman want it didn't feel like
the one from Bob Hastings as named
from the enemy it seriesiny those were
strong good Gordon's and I don't know
this just felt very forced and very fake
and I could not get into the emotion of
it and that is a problem I mean cuz that
is like the emotional center of the
story I know some people think his bad
girl by me she's in a very briefly and
she's gone that visual certainly sticks
with you but you know it's kind of there
and then it's gone so I think with him
not having that emotional strength there
I felt it suffered a little bit there
too but um yeah I still it's still so
cool to see this comic that is just such
a strong comic I mean such a strong
story of being brought to life in this
animated realm and I wish it could have
been phenomenal but then again honestly
from what I heard going into this I'm
kind of glad I got what I got when it
actually was The Killing Joke and yes it
is awful that that first half hour is
there and that clearly so much work went
into it like I say it looks gorgeous and
the actors are great and it's good
pacing and everything but it just has
nothing to do with anything it's like a
short before movie starts except it just
keeps going on and on then it tries to
make the excuse there's a connection
what it doesn't it has no connection um
and I've yet to see anyone that's like
that was a good addition I have not met
a person it was this one from like being
the most anticipated a DC project for a
long time say that animated DC a project
I mean like ever made uh you know to a
point where it's like they're showing in
theaters and stuff to the most despised
like as soon as that footage came out
everyone was like what the hell have you
done and then when they saw it it's like
nope that didn't help so it's very very
poorly written and that's what ruins it
everything else about it is fine but it
is just so horribly written it can't
recover from that uh but like I said
because it is so separated for for me uh
I I can just very easily tune it out I
can pretend that never happened it
really has so little connection it is
not hard to do it is not hard just the
totally for
get that first half-hour happen so with
that taken out uh everyone some people
can't do that it's that's gonna be too
distracting that's gonna be how did this
connect why was this here why was it and
I totally get that I'm good at blocking
that out so as like a complete work does
it work no but as going from The Killing
Joke on uh I think it's pretty strong uh
it's not quite phenomenal it's not quite
great but this is this is tricky this is
hard to make phenomenal you know
transitions and adaptations are very
very difficult and this one granted is
so visually pleasing and the story is so
strong the writing so strong but you got
to make those changes and they do make a
few I think they needed a few more I
think they really needed to expand a
little bit more to make it phenomenal
but as is when The Killing Joke part
starts I think it's pretty damn good and
I would still recommend it with the idea
that you can just fast-forward that
first half-hour and it's it's not hard
to spot even the visual style kind of
looks different when you're
fast-forwarding just fast-forward look
for the rain when you see the rain on
the ground view okay and this is where
my movie is starting and they didn't
need to make it a half an hour and a
half's Naima has an hour 16 minutes
didn't need to do that I think people
would have been totally happy with
whatever it'd be 40 minutes 50 minutes
I'm like that 45 minutes
um I think we would have been totally
satisfied or you could have taken that
extra time to really kind of explore
this stuff a little bit more visually
and maybe with music and maybe kind of
with different angles I think you can
stretch this out enough and we would
have been okay because it does not have
to be a cinematic running time yeah I
can be whatever you want it's these DC
anime movies it can be whatever um so
and if for some reason there is
something like way you can't show into
theater unless it's the certain amount
of time show Batman cartoon before show
something from the animated series we
would love that
how cool would it be and we see a Batman
and Joker a cartoon like you know from
the Batman animated series and then you
see The Killing Joke like you just feel
like all those years have passed in
between and you see the contrast between
them how great
then um but instead we have this dumb
1/2 hour and it does like I said I
haven't seen anyone that likes it uh
maybe you're out there I don't know but
I haven't seen him yet
um but yeah so I would still recommend
this I really would I would say just get
the first half hour so that's my take on
I wanted to review that actually talked
about the goddamn killing joke cuz
nobody was talking about The Killing
Joke uh and I told him Stan first half
hour is unbelievably distracting but
yeah why people actually talk about that
main part and really focus on it so I
still highly recommend it now my Killing
Joke story um because this is so
embarrassing it makes me look like a
dumbass but I feel that's the fun thing
of admitting it so when I read Killing
Joke I read it when first came out
everyone the or at least around when the
Batman movie came out the Tim Burton one
and I saw this and I was obsessed with a
dark Joker and everything I read the
story whoa whoa holy shit what was that
um and I loved it but here's the thing
and this gets into spoiler territory so
if you have not read the comics in the
movie this is literally the ending so do
not watch anymore you know my opinion at
the very end of this story
I thought Batman killed the Joker all
these years that's what I thought
happened and the reason for that is uh
in the movie you see Joker tells us joke
his famous joke and Batman starts
laughing then they both start laughing
uncontrollably and then in this you see
quite clear that he puts his hands on
the Joker's shoulders like that like
he's just laughing so hard he cave and
contain himself like he's almost kind of
giving in to the madness too and they
both had this really good laugh and all
the stuff he can read into that it's
just gonna keep going and the cycle and
stuff like that and they each give in to
the each other's own insanity um but in
the comic the way was drawn I thought he
was strangling him that is always what I
thought was going on I thought he was
laughing as he was strangling him he was
still and ha ha ha ha then it cuts to
the rain and I just thought it was kind
of left open whether or not he killed
him uh now some people might say well
it's the stories after that you know
show he's still alive and stuff but it's
kind of like in mask of the phantasm
it's like yeah it's kind of it's
continuing in the story but it's also
kind of its own thing too because they
want to see the mask of the phantasm you
know how that ends or do you how does
that end do you know kind of a similar
idea uh so I always thought for years
The Killing Joke was the literal Killing
Joke
I thought Joker said this joke just
finally push Batman over the edge I mean
the whole thing is talking about you
know the one these days one of us gonna
kill the other it has to stop I thought
just that was it that was the joke and
he just acts dummy axed him off uh so I
for years until I saw this was under the
impression that he most likely killed
the Joker and that is my incredibly
stupid dumbass way of looking at it so
I'll give maybe I'll give the Killing
Joke p.m. a movie there too it's that it
clarified something I clearly was not
figuring out I like I didn't know it was
like whatever final like you know they
didn't show like the body or anything
but I thought they were hinting that he
was actually strangling him and then it
cuts to the rain and we don't know what
happened kind of thing so yeah that's my
dumbass moment I just thought when I
watched this I was just like oh so that
wasn't what I was supposed to interpret
all these years uh and I never really
talked about with anybody because I just
kind of assumed it was obvious that you
know that's what Batman was doing but it
wasn't he was putting his hands on his
shoulders so that's oh that's my
incredibly embarrassing story about it
um it makes you look like a dummy but I
don't care I think it's kind of funny
and if there's anything that we can take
from these Killing Joke stories and
interpretations and stuff is that you
know what a low humor can go a long way
so that's about it that's my
embarrassing story that's my take on The
Killing Joke I hope you enjoyed it and
more V logs and real thoughts and
reviews are coming your way so
definitely keep an eye on those late